[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime bien tous les jours je travaille
pas directement bien sûr au supermarché
après exactement faire sa ronde savait
que le 25 novembre 2010 benjamin
castaldi était l'invité touche pas à mon
poste sur france 4
alors en voyant cette émission je me
suis rendu compte qu'il avait sorti la
meilleure vannes de sa vie surtout quand
on sait ce qui est arrivé récemment
c'est magnifique vraiment bungie
art
vous réveiller très tôt pour aller faire
un cap 5 heures du matin alors si vous
avez un bon ou pas je suis certaine
galop c'est donc la barre à main cela
raconte comme jamais car il se lève à 4
heures pour faire du cheval
wahou mais la vanne arrive la vanne
arrivé aussi professionnelle 2 à huy
pour être prendre de plongée mais alors
un projet pas très doué alors
non j'ai plongé j'ai changé et il n'y
avait pas assez de son prof de pandémie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quant à elle servait les yeux beaucoup
plus ouvre sans un mot les frères mais
fou non
mais je te jure que tu es beau comme ça
on dirait christophe lambert et il le
fait bien et c'était jure ben on aura un
très beau christory l'arcep à la
question vous appellerez les deux alors
je dis c'était grand retour aux balances
ton post l'émission qui est comme tpm
paix sauf que les chroniqueurs ont fait
des études
alors ils ont tous fait des très bons
nation je me mets dedans vous inquiétez
pas alors ça n'inquiète pas alors c'est
la première de raquel garrido l'ancien
porte parole de jean luc mélenchon et
comme c'était sa première bien entendu
pour l'accueillir ses nouveaux collègues
ont évidemment décidé de l'attaquer tout
le ministre il n'y a pas toute la soirée
série vous le défendez vous défendez et
puis finalement vous dit allez y a pas
de raison moi aussi je vais m'y mettre
regardez c'est sur un air garrido
des tricks niek ça commence ouais c'est
vrai débat les débats me manquer je
pense qu elle trépigne et de parler
beaucoup et fort solide avec naulleau
qui se targue d'être un grand lecteur
qui défend lui le racket trépigne à
l'idée de se friter avec eric naulleau
cas les expressions qui étaient à la
mode en 1953 monarchie présidentielle
c'est un des vieux dada de la france un
somme il est j'enfourche dada c'est à
dada sur mon bide alors à qu'elle parle
tellement fort garder la tête d'eric
naulleau et surtout celle de karim
zéribi au coût de 10 missions il un peu
plus de leur jeu attend pas moins de
crier du moca sur le sujet bon à quel
point fort est tout le temps même quand
le public applaudit et au bout de deux
heures d'émission même cyril hanouna
il craque tata raphaël est cassée par
laquelle quand je parle de tête
sur energa
[Applaudissements]
c'est se classera sincèrement elle a
fait une rentrée exceptionnelle on dit
le montage reflète pas les missions mais
là totalement totalement l'émission est
là elle a été elle a été fixée par
regarder ça très très belle rentrée
alors danser que de la télé avec valérie
benaïm on le sait il y a le ca j'ai
toujours rêvé de faire ça et rier depuis
le débu t t 1 p j'ai remarqué ici qui
avait signé le onzième chroniqueurs ah
oui c'est une personne que vous
connaissez très bien
alors oui c'est très très bien c'est
qu'on pouvait deviner un pyramides comme
d'habitude assure en asie c'est dur
c'est dur c'est pas ben non c'est pas
castonguay un papa maman bravo aux
wallons qui adore les missions et qui au
fil des saisons noires sms est devenu un
peu la snipe aux rsa la preuve
[Musique]
si je me suis là ça veut dire tu vas
voir le ba ba va mal décidément je
l'aurais jamais il ya quand même ma mère
qui moment un texto ou les valérie et 2
tu l'as eu le bac abruti
il y en a même qui m'envoie un texto
baba tu fais comme arthur tu rejoins
touche je reçois toujours elie semoun
voilà donc tout on rigolait et te moquer
d'arthur t'es qu'une merde
peu plus de béré bien m'envoyer à spa
les sièges
elle m'a dit baba c'est le moment de
kent sa grand-mère à montiel mais non il
m'a traitée dans la rue mais lui s'il
s'en souvient
[Musique]
la bnr serait forcée de ricains
merci surtout quand vous savez que dans
tous les jt on parle des chiffres du
cacao mais depuis quelques mois on parle
encore pouls des chiffres du classement
2 n'oubliez pas de prendre la parole ça
ça leur fait peur et le pire c'est que
c'est vrai ça leur fait vraiment peur je
compte chaque intervention des
chroniqueurs pendant la semaine
précédente pourrait dans le classement
il faut avoir fait au moins trois
émissions sur quatre alors qui est le
plus parler qu'il est resté le presque
muet voici au dernier classement de
n'oubliez pas de prendre la parole
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans votre
classement 2 n'oubliez pas de prendre
cette semaine en dernière position il va
se présenter tout seul très intervention
seulement pour celui qui sans conteste
sera un futur grand animateur télé vie
juste après ça on ne vient position on
retrouve avec 22,7 invention la seule
chroniqueuse qui c'est qu'alexandre
dumas n'était pas seulement une station
de métro
géraldine maillet quand il est je suis
mignon mignon mais gros vous avez pensé
à vous sur la tête de ma mère ou du
classement avec 42 interventions celui
qui cherche toujours à aller en
profondeur jean-michel mais le meilleur
moment à las vegas comme vous êtes
il a été enfermé en dehors de sa chance
et donc on est obligé de traverser tout
le tel un petit slip et s'est marié 40
ans tu annonçant le meilleur moment de
ta vie c'est qu'on est encore en
première position cette semaine
52 c'est son nombre d'interventions la
semaine dernière mais aussi aux non aux
téléspectateurs de des pmp people
matthieu delormeau
on se connaissait pas et et 4 heures du
matin on fait ça un petit peu rapidement
déjà mais très fier dans ces moments là
et évidemment il y avait un colloque
donc on sera mis dans le noir et tout ça
quand j'arrive chez moi c'était pas mes
baskets c'était les siennes et j'étais
parti que son portable
vous êtes repartis avec votre sac
[Applaudissements]